bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on voit que la colère
des arméniens ne retombe pas un suite à
cet accord l'opposition est même monté
au créneau contre le premier ministre
nikol pashinian est menacé selon vous il
pourrait perdre sa place
oui c'est pas c'est pas exclu parce que
on sait que la vie politique arménienne
ces dernières années a été extrêmement
agitée il ya eu à plusieurs reprises des
sorte de révolution de palais des des
votes qui ont modifié les équilibres
institutionnels
sachant aussi que l'opposition pendant
20 ans ceux qui ont gouverné l'arménie
c'était des représentants du karabagh et
malheureusement je dirais à aucun moment
les dirigeants arméniens
c'était pareil du côté un servette janet
d'ailleurs non préparer leurs opinions
publiques à une paix un compromis
c'est-à-dire au point nécessaire pour
que cette situation de conflit gelé qui
n'en était pas un parce qu'il y avait
des des morts pratiquement tous les mois
pour que cette situation soit réglé
diplomatiquement justement l'arrêt des
hostilités au karabagh qui s'accompagne
le rappel de la rétrocession de vastes
territoires à l'azerbaïdjan
c'était le seul moyen pour préserver
cette région disputée on sait qu
l'arménité au bord de la débâcle
oui je pense que depuis le depuis le
cessez le feu de 1994 qui avait entériné
une situation où les arméniens avaient
gagné la guerre
il avait le contrôle de pratiquement
tout le karabagh proprement dit et il
avait aussi le contrôle de deux grandes
territoire de l'azerbaïdjan il n'avait
jamais été dans le karabagh et donc
depuis le début on savait qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faudrait rendre certains
territoires
or
cette second premier n'a jamais pu être
réellement mises en mise en place et non
seulement cela mais de au fonds beaucoup
d'arméniens considéré que ces terres qui
avait été gagné par la guerre resterait
arménienne de toute éternité
or ce n'est pas possible parce que on
voyait bien ce qui se passe est que le
rapport de force est en train de changer
que l'armée azerbaïdjanaise augmenter
ses capacités
on savait pas à ce moment là on pouvait
pas imaginer que la turquie rentrerait
dans le jeu et qu'il y aurait des
mercenaires turcs mais on savait que il
ya une disproportion flagrante des
budgets militaires donc 7,7 et monsieur
alief le père comme le fils ont toujours
dit que s'il n'y avait pas de solution
diplomatique négocier eh bien il
faudrait passer par une phase militaire
alors l'accord a été signé à ce léger de
moscou il prévoit justement le
déploiement de soldats russes qui
d'ailleurs sont sont arrivés hier sur
place est ce que la russie a conforté
d'une manière ou d'une autre sa position
dans le caucase du sud mais également
l'indépendance de l'arménie à son égard
oui et non je dirais oui et non c'est
effectivement moscou qui a négocié ce
cessez le feu et je crois que c'est une
très bonne chose parce qu'il fallait que
les combats s'arrêtent et de ce point de
vue là moscou a joué la carte de ses
bons rapports et avec l'arménie et avec
l'azerbaïdjan
mais je crois que c'était c'est à
camphin le ce cycle de combat et ce
cessez-le-feu marque aussi une grande
faiblesse de la russie qui d'une part
n'a pas en n'a pas pu empêcher que les
turcs rentrer dans le jeu d'une façon
majeure et je pense que la turquie est
bien plus gagnant dans cette affaire que
la russie parce que pour la réussit ça
signifie la concrétisation de son
affaiblissement de la maîtrise du jeu au
caucase sud et je crois que ça et en
plus on ne sait pas encore qu'est ce qui
va se passer en arménie c'est à dire que
si effectivement monsieur pashinian est
renversé et si à sa place revienne
une coalition antérieur il y à gros à
parier que que moscou soit mis en
accusation pour ne pas avoir aider
l'arménie comme il fallait donc donc je
vois là je crois que c'est une très
bonne chose que ce cessez le feu et été
négocié et j'espère qu'il sera maintenu
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit une
victoire de la motion émotion
la turquie est donc à quai le grand
soutien de bakou vous venez de le dire
gagner un petit peu en influence dans
cette région
on a entendu les propos du président
azerbaïdjanais ilham aliev qui reste
très virulent quand même dans ses propos
vis-à-vis de l'arménie est ce qu'on peut
craindre une reprise du conflit s'il
cessez le feu oui on peut bien entendu
dans un cas comme ça on peut craindre
une reprise du conflit mais il ya un
facteur nouveau quand même qui est laid
des deux mille hommes avec du matériel
important russe qui est vrai qu'il va
s'interposer donc on peut espérer cette
interposition fonctionnent en même temps
les mots très durs de monsieur aliev son
sont inquiétants parce qu'il a traité
les arméniens de chiens etc
c'est une rhétorique alors bien sûr
c'est une rhétorique patriotique
nationaliste qui acquit un discours
interne à l'azerbaïdjan il ya aussi une
chose qui a changé de façon importante
c'est le le corridor qui va être établi
entre l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie
et ça c'est une nouveauté géo
stratégique importante qui est là aussi
une concession
enfin les arméniens ont dû concéder cela
et c'est une concession de moscou aussi
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
jean radvanyi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
géographe et spécialiste du caucase à
professeur émérite à l'inalco